hi there steve kaufman here
i want to continue on the subject of
corrections
because it seems to generate quite a bit
of interest from
people commenting here at my youtube
channel and people say why are you so
sensitive about people who correct you
and how will people ever improve if they
aren't corrected
and these kinds of things now i
apologize that on these rants of mine i
don't have my thoughts necessarily
always
well organized because it's all i can do
to find the time to sit down here and
talk in front of the video so i'm going
to ramble a bit here but
the common question is number one
uh why is it that you're so sensitive
why don't you like to be
corrected
well
when i think about it
uh
i like doing things in language learning
that are meaningful i like to listen to
things that interest me
and when i speak to people i want it to
be a meaningful conversation i don't
like pretending that i'm at the bank at
the train station in a restaurant role
playing
none of that stuff appeals to me
when i start speaking to people as i'm
doing now in romanian
we're talking about
okay how was your day how was work but
then we're talking about
romanian food we're talking about
romanian history romanian geography
present-day romanian politics things
that interest me so i'm totally into
those conversations
and to me the important thing about
speaking and and output
is that that you are doing it it's the
act of of immersing yourself in the
language using the language that is the
most important so while i'm doing this
and searching for words
uh if i'm corrected i find it quite
off-putting so i don't like it for that
reason
and i think most people if they were
honest
don't like it unless they're in a
classroom where they feel they've paid
the instructor
to correct them and they're not getting
their money's worth if the instructor
doesn't correct them
but if i meet someone here in
my daily life in vancouver
uh who is let's say an immigrant and
we're having a conversation let's say a
salesman comes to me this happens a
salesman comes and doesn't speak perfect
english or somebody that i deal with
at the store or
somewhere doesn't speak perfect english
it would never cross my mind to correct
them they're operating in the language
you know it's like at a restaurant if
i'm at a korean restaurant and the
prayer the waitress speaks to me or any
you know
restaurant that speaks to me in english
and i'll correct them no that's not how
you say it i mean that's you just don't
do that because it's off-putting when
people are genuinely trying to
communicate so that's why i don't like
it
uh
to me the conversation the big thing
about the conversation is that it's it's
an opportunity for more input i'm
listening to the native speaker and i'm
listening for the words that the native
speaker uses and at times when i search
for words the native speaker will
volunteer the words i'm learning the
words
and as content a conversation is
tremendously powerful it's it has it's
what i call high resonance because
you're in that discussion and you're
searching for words and maybe the native
speaker provides the words
uh and you're listening to the words
that they're using so it's very high
resonance very effective input and it's
a prac it's an opportunity to practice
output but as much as that or more so
it's a tremendously rich input
opportunity and so the more i speak the
more the native speaker speaks the more
natural and flowing our conversation the
more i benefit the more i'm immersed
language learning is more about
immersion
than
correction or perfection
so that was the first one why do i not
like being corrected second comment i
get is how are you ever going to improve
how are people going to improve if you
don't correct them well my
take on that is how do you know that
correcting them improves them that's the
whole point we have no proof the
assumption is that correcting people
improves them
i think that that's not true at all
because
in any language there is so much to
learn it's not just
the tremendous variety of structures and
forms that we can use it's even the
words themselves the phrases themselves
phrasal verbs how many phrasal verbs are
there in english uh
the fact that a word
that you looked up in the dictionary may
not have in fact the same meaning or
being may not be used the same way in
another language there's an almost
infinite variety of things you cannot
learn all of those things based on
feedback and instruction from a native
speaker those are all things that you
have to acquire yourself naturally
through a lot of exposure and when you
first start out and if you read you know
teach yourself or whatever they
introduce some concepts
90 of them are over your head you can't
deal with these things
at first but as you start to become
familiar with some elements now you can
go back again and look at some of the
other elements that were introduced that
are over your head and so gradually
as you gain more and more confidence and
as long as you remain motivated
to improve
then you will improve essentially on
your own not because people correct you
people cannot possibly correct you for
all of the issues that you're going to
come across in the language in fact the
number of things they can correct is
very small
and the things that they will tend to
correct very often are things that are
very
tenacious as errors
uh we've often mentioned this third
person singular present tense in english
he go people say he go instead of he
goes i've often talked about
chinese people
they continue to say my husband she
because in chinese they don't have in
speaking a difference between he and she
correcting them is not going to change
that at some point they have to start
noticing it and it has to become part of
the way they use the language so
i don't think that correcting
people
in fact improves them it may have a
minor effect primarily people have to do
it on their own so the question how will
they ever improve if you don't correct
them they do not improve because you
correct them they improve if they put
the time and effort into
uh correcting themselves and
those people who have been the most
corrected in classrooms and so forth uh
esl classes they often speak the worst
and people who have been out exposing
themselves to the language naturally
they often speak
better
but still you have to be motivated to
try to improve so if i speak to uh
you know there's a vietnamese gardener
that comes around
our house once every two weeks i mean
his he he speaks a lot uh but he's never
made a particularly
uh you know concerted effort to work on
his language if i were to correct him
when he speaks it would have no impact
on him whatsoever none zero uh if on the
other hand he undertook to do a lot of
reading and listening and focusing in on
those structures that he had difficulty
with
he might improve i had made some notes
here i think that's about
uh yeah
another part of this is
uh
language learning has to come from
outside in because you don't have the
language in you and it comes from
overwhelmingly from input all right when
you're talking about correction
you're talking about
output
first and foremost because if i'm not
outputting anything you can't correct me
the major part of language learning
takes place
when we are ingesting taking the
language in because we don't have the
language in ourselves the language has
to come from
what native speakers have written
or said
so that the the main thrust in language
learning is input and contrary to what
many people seem to believe i do not
believe
that the doing part role playing
speaking answering questions drills all
of that
is
where you learn the language you can do
those things or not do them
but you learn the language by hearing it
and seeing it and noticing it
and you don't have to do a lot of
speaking
an example is
by romanian overwhelmingly i just listen
and read and
yeah i mean when i get to romania i will
do a video in cebu i'm going to be in
cebu on the 8th and 9th of june and
there's an international theater
festival there so i'm going to try and
shoot some video while i'm in cebu and
i'm going to speak some romanian but i
haven't spoken very much
because the language has to come from
outside and so when you do speak the
main thing is to immerse yourself in
speaking
just communicating listening to what the
other person is
saying
and don't turn these opportunities for
communication into classroom sessions
into sterile classroom sessions with a
lot of correction it doesn't help
research says it doesn't help my
experience says it doesn't help but i
will say that if that's what you like if
you like to be corrected by all means
ask people to correct you but if people
don't ask to be corrected you shouldn't
correct them
so
one more
rant on the issue of corrections i look
forward to your comments
bye for now